do you remember the first time you
picked up a camera
i do i have i have a little uh
photograph of it
um and it's me and
uh therese who was this friend of my
parents and there's a picture of me with
this it's not a box brownie but it's
like it's one
level up from that and you can see me
kind of struggling with the controls
and um i guess i must have been
free something like that
and um and then later on i picked up my
father's
um he had this kodak camera that had the
bellows that opens up and the bellows
stick out and i did a lot of my early
work with that camera
and why not keep it as a hobby what how
did you
so many kids pick up gadgets of all
sorts why
continue on i suppose
i it was kind of in the family because
my
my father uh worked for the bbc he was a
drama producer and he
he was one of the pioneers of three
camera drama
um and purdue he produced about an hour
of live television every week
and even though i could see the stress
on his face you know it was it was
definitely an area that i was going into
some of my earliest memories
of my father was he would come home and
he would work
at home and he had a map of the
planned view of the studio and
then because the cameras were all they
all had cables on them
he would have a piece of string on this
like plastic representation of the
camera
and and where it plugged into the uh the
wall
and his um his
job was to block the show without a
camera ever running over another cable
because they were on wheels and they
couldn't
they couldn't run over the cable so uh
that's like a very early memory of
uh me and uh his his workflow
but um no it do
i only really ever wanted to be two
things and one one was a film director
and the other one was a rock and roll
star
so i kind of like and john bonham was
already
exactly right it was a crowded
profession
you grew up in the united kingdom i did
i i was born in central london
on the topman court road and
i believe we spent our early
years in notting hill gate and then we
moved out to what was
then the country but it was really
suburbia
to a place called bushy heath which is
near watford
which is where elton john
owned his football team so that gives
you a reference
and it was also situated halfway between
l street studios and pinewood studios
so for me it was a really good place to
live because i could commute to either
one of those studios
[Music]
and then at what point did you leave the
uk
well i
got a my dream job which was to work for
my
favorite director ever um stanley
kubrick
on a movie called 2001 a space odyssey
and that was when i was 19 years old
and so i worked for
like two and a half years on that movie
which is actually the longest gainful
employment that i've ever had in my life
you know in one stretch and
uh at the end of that movie i was asked
by doug trumbull who had originally
hired me onto that movie
to come and work for his new special
effects company
in california
so i came right after that movie in 1968
and really i've been here ever since so
uh
it's my country sure
at that time what what was kubrick's um
he wouldn't have been a legend of course
at that time as he was
in his 20s or early 30s he was
i'm not sure what age she was but he was
definitely a legend
you know my dad had taken me to see
uh positive glory which was his first
big picture i think with kirk douglas
and they had these wonderful tracking
shots through the
world war one trenches and it was also a
courtroom drama
so i think that was you know before that
he had done the killer's kiss and the
killing
but they were they were smaller movies
so i think powers of glory was his first
uh you know really big movie um
and then you know he made movies like
lolita
and uh dr strangelove or
how i learned to stop worrying about
the bomb and love it you know i think
that's my line the movie
um and um
no he was he for me and because my dad
had taken me to see all these movies and
then some of them i went to
on my own he was a pretty big deal he
was my
he was my favorite director so to get
hired by him
um that movie was uh the stars must have
aligned very carefully for me to
get that opportunity and you know i had
some really
good breaks in my life you know but um
i've always been ready for them i'd
always laid the groundwork
so when i got when i got the call to
work on that movie
i had um i had a um
a very strong training in animation
so i was hired as an animation artist
and
then they when they found out i could
shoot animation
i became especially interesting to them
because
um there's a process in animation where
the animators animate
and then the animator they write a dope
sheet which is an instruction
sheet to tell the um
the cameraman how to shoot it so it's
all
it's like frame by frame it tells the
camera
what to do so i was able to do the
artwork
and then put it under the camera and i
skipped that dope sheet
phase of the process so i became very
useful to them
in that way and that's how i
got promoted very quickly you know do
you remember what it was like the first
day you reported for the job
um yeah i was excited to be there
but uh i certainly wasn't nervous about
it you know it was uh
i think it's the arrogance of youth that
you don't really know what you stepped
into
and
i just felt i felt very at home i felt
very supported by everybody that was
around me
and you know i i had this
background in animation i taught myself
you know i was a huge disney fan as a
kid
and when i was about 12 i wrote a book
on
how to animate cartoons which was a
focal press book
and i taught myself how to animate and
to do cells
and then my dad bought me a
9.5 millimeter camera which
was able to take single frames so now i
was able to get my animated drawings
and turn them into animated films so i
had done that
and then um after
uh school i got hired by an animation
company
to do to be a trainee rostrum cameraman
a russian russian cameraman is the name
of an animation
or a photography process
so i had done that and um
so i had this whole background that i've
been working on for years so it it
seemed like i
i got this really lucky opportunity and
i jumped right into it but i had this
underlying base of the knowledge
and practical skill in that
before i before i got there do you
remember your first meeting with stanley
kubrick
i do originally when i came to work at
mgm we were
in the front offices because the
um the production hadn't really taken
over the studio as it would in
you know within within six months we
were on every stage in every department
but at the moment
that we were in this little tiny uh
front office building
you know that had probably about uh
eight or ten offices in that
and um so i had started off working
in in this room uh with doug trumbull
who had hired me
and another guy from the film board of
canada called wally gentleman
and there was stanley just kind of like
walking walking through the offices and
um
he seemed very relaxed he uh
was smiling and laughing and joking and
they're
a very affable guy you know and
and very very personable so he was
you know pleased to meet you and uh
it was uh i remember well he came in
with uh arthur clarke who had written
or co-written uh 2001 with him
he had written a short story that
stanley had based it on
and yeah they were just wandering
through the office there was no like
formality to it you know it was just
it was very nice and and stanley's
office
remained open throughout the
uh throughout the production so you
could go into his office he had
he had a knower on his wall saying no
half-baked ideas
you know you don't want to come in with
anything that you haven't thought about
and present to him that's not
not a formalized plan you know so
very interesting guy you know so really
an open door policy not just what some
hr paperwork says
exactly yes yeah and and you know
he was um
you know he had some strange foibles to
him
he he he liked to have nothing in his
pockets
so i think i think he come in in america
you have to carry your id
and your wallet and your car keys and
you know so he had
he had nothing on him um
so he would bum cigarettes off other
people so he didn't have to have a pack
of cigarettes on him
um and uh he
drove in this classic rolls royce
that was at the studio
and uh he had a driver but that was
really the only
uh the only kind of uh you
that you could call formal pretence or
something that's around
it and and i have to say i was very
irresponsible
kid when i was on it and i would
frequently be late to work so it would
be like 9
30 and i'm coming into the parking lot
and the only the only other guy that's
walking into the studio was was stanley
you know
and he he never seemed to be angry with
me for not being
it was just like a nice polite wave and
i'd go in so
um so it was weird because
um there wasn't really a pressure to
work the pressure of the work was on you
so as i um
so it seemed like i would come in and
with would
look around and we'd talk about what
we'd done the day before and
then it was tea time and then we'd have
tea and then
it seemed like nothing really got done
before lunch
and then and then round about three
o'clock i'd start
really uh shooting in earnest and by the
end of the day i'd got more uh footage
shot than
anybody else that was doing the same
kind of work you know so uh
it was the arrogance of you
but uh i guess with some talent you know
did you have long hair i did uh-huh
i think that's another reason i was
hired you know oh he looks like the
beatles you know we should uh
we should hire him were you well
received
being so young on the set or were there
other people that were 19
20 um
no there weren't people as young as me i
was really
the youngest around and
i was very well received in our little
group but i think a lot of
people in the english film industry
it's a much more kind of closed um
and um nepotistic
loop you know than uh than it is here
and that was one of the great things
about coming to america
was everybody was very open about
everything and
invested in your success but there was
always kind of like a
there was always a feeling like oh he's
he's he's
around he's maybe uh a little too big
for his britches you know
over there so um some you know the
people in our department were very
um very enthusiastic
and and helpful but others were a little
like what
what's he doing here you know that's uh
i'm not sure about that you know
do you think that stanley maybe saw a
younger version of himself
sort of just a sort of a free-spirited
and and
maybe unintended i don't know about the
arrogance part but just unintentional
sort of just
idealistic you know free spirit
possibly possibly i never really uh i
never really saw it that way you know
but i did you know
because i idolized him so much um
i had asked him this one of my last
meetings with him on the movie i said
well
say well where do you get where do you
get your ideas for your movies from
where the
where the and he said well ah that's the
uh
[Music]
that's a very good question you know
and he had no answer for me
so aside from him having this
real open door policy did you learn
anything from how he dealt with people
or how he worked maybe just him being
open and relaxed and joking
that you kind of wanted to emulate
yourself i think
probably my style of directing is is
similar to his in that way except that
i'm
you know i've never had the luxury of
being able to be quite the perfectionist
he was because you know he was certainly
known
in his later movies for uh i think
scat man crothers or something did 70
odd takes of something in the shining
you know so um
so he would he he was known for shooting
many many versions of it you know
and usually what i find if i shoot a lot
of takes it's usually the um it's
usually take one
um or possibly the last take but you
know
um but um
i i i think the uh
style of being relaxed on the set you
know i've worked with some
pretty heavy-duty directors that like to
shout a lot and throw their weight
around and
you know to me that's not the way to get
the uh the most out of a crew
you know how did you become the
cinematographer on tron
i have no idea uh i went for a meeting
uh with the director steve lisberger
at the disney studios i'm not
quite sure how i got that meeting or how
it was set up but
i think it was from my other friends in
the business who reckon
they recommended me but then i i
got into the office and it was almost
like i had the job before i even
like began began the interview you know
so i have no recollection of being
interviewed for the job it was just like
well this is this is what we're doing
and they're
gonna um let's let's go let's uh
let's get it together and do it so there
wasn't much of an audition process there
but um but there again at that movie
because of its uh technical challenges
there were um they they were
i don't think they were green lit uh
totally when
when i took my meeting and got involved
in it
so there were some screen tests and uh
different proofs of concept that disney
wanted before the
show moved forward and so i was involved
on those
and so you know slowly you know
everything came together and we got
green lit this got greenlit and that got
greenlit and then finally we were
making the movie you know so it was a
process
how did it work with the cinematography
and then the effects
like how was that especially in the
early 80s
well there were three um three aspects
of tron there was the live action and
then there was the cg animation
and the the first cg animation ever
ever used on a movie
and then there was stuff that was
created to be in the
uh cyberspace electronic world
footage that was based on live action
now that live action was
you know everybody was wearing like
black and white suits
and it was shot in 70 millimeter
and they took every frame that we shot
and they blew it up onto a 16 inch wide
codalist
and then those were put under the
animation stand
and shot with colored gels and diffusion
filters
and so um it became an animation process
and there were a lot of things that we
had to do
to make sure that when the black and
white photography was blown up onto
these
high contrast cells that they would work
in the animation process
and mostly to do with having very very
sharp
frames because um
there's something called motion blur in
photography which
is when something moves in front of a
motion picture camera things
blur and so for instance if they had a
line on their suit
and they were in motion
if that line wasn't perfectly sharp
it would just disappear from the
codeless negative
so um we had to have infinite depth of
field
we had to have a very short shutter
which meant that every image was like
perfectly sharp
you know and
and all that required a tremendous
amount of light
and the fastest film that we could use
and the uh the fastest um
um on the the other thing to create that
depth of field we need to
shoot at a very uh very high aperture
you know so a lot of the stuff was shot
around f8 and
uh f16 uh excuse me f11
um which required a tremendous amount of
light
and uh in fact uh burbank water and
power
called the studio twice during our
production said you're using too much
electricity if you gotta
we're gonna shut you down if you don't
uh use a little bit less so
oh wow we were welding with light on
that movie you know
so they must have they saw the the usage
from
wherever they were absolutely for the
meter oh interesting
it peaked and they could tell where it
was coming from you know
how long was the actual shooting of the
film not not these other processes
but uh i think tron
i think we shot for 69 days
and i think the
the regular live action schedule um
because we shot up in lawrence livermore
labs
up there at the shiva
laser lab and
then we shot sets on stage
so i think that was about
25 days all that kind of live action and
the rest was this
hybrid black and white
uh photography that was later then going
to be
treated um on the animation stand
as uh special effects footage
do you remember uh what it was like to
see the premiere
to attend it
yes um no i just i remember the
uh i remember the they had a
uh they had a black and white ball where
i i guess the the women wore white
and the men wore black and it was at the
beverly wilshire hotel
and uh that that was a pretty fun event
i
don't remember the premiere of trauma
it's terrible well maybe it was a good
night then
maybe a lot maybe a lot of people didn't
know because
the story of toronto is strange because
um
you know it it was a picture that
disney had hyped a lot and then somebody
came out in the um
[Music]
in the wall street journal and said this
is not the movie that's going to save
the disney studio
and their stock dropped like two and two
and a quarter points
and um then there was the premiere of
the movie
and one week later et came out
so uh it really kind of got eclipsed
and then then somebody else at the
studio said
okay we don't want this we want to take
this
out of uh distribution because we want
to
release the dvd at christmas you know
so uh when it came out i don't think it
was
it wasn't really that successful but
after you know after the summer it
started to pick up its own
pace you know and then suddenly they
they cut it off to do dvd sales so
but now it's classic so it doesn't
really make any difference in there
were those the big video discs that you
would kind of put in a laserdisc
yes i remember yeah much many movies but
also
um videotape i think as well
vhs yeah
so how was that to probably be so
thrilled to work on something that's
groundbreaking
you put so many days in what almost 70
days of shooting time and then
additional and post or whatever and then
to have
like a well-respected publication just
come and just
for whatever the agenda maybe there
wasn't any but just
kind of crush it well it must have been
a lot worse for steven lesberger than
for me you know but um
uh you know my my work had been over for
a long time because
obviously there was a live action
schedule that i was involved in
but the whole post schedule was about a
year so we're talking about a project
that
i finished a year beforehand before it
before it was premiered
so um i do remember the first time i saw
the movie was that the
um was at the chinese theater on
hollywood boulevard
and it was supposedly projected in 70
millimeter
and the
projections had it out of focus for the
whole
the whole show and i would like i was
trying to go back and say it's a lot
sharper it's a lot better than this you
know but
but that's something you get used to is
like your uh just distribution of your
product is not always at the quality or
that you uh
shot the movie at but now with um
digital um all that's kind of
going away and you know i think
digital media is a lot more um
i think it's a lot easier the chances of
you seeing the way it was shot
are a lot better in the digital world
than uh
having you a print at a road show at a
theater
you know and with a with a projector
bulb that the guy
doesn't want to run it at full voltage
because the the bulb will last a little
bit longer
so yes i embrace the digital edge
when you booked your job on star wars at
that time
how big a deal was it was it similar to
today booking a job
on avengers or because it was a smaller
movie i think what he was sharing the
casting space with um
brian de palma and they were making
carry they were kind of swapping actors
i don't know do you want this person
i'll take them yeah okay
i like that mark hamill guys i haven't i
hadn't heard that story oh okay
i like that supposedly on the carry
behind the scenes
they said that yeah but how i'm sorry so
how was that to uh
to work was it was it not a huge deal at
that moment because
we didn't know the effect of it well um
i had originally uh interviewed
with george lucas and gary kurtz
to to do the visual effects to be the
to be the first unit our visual effects
director
and um i
you know i had i spent a lot of
time in my early career saying uh oh
i've done that i don't want to do that
anymore i cannot
i'm going in this new direction so
um so i had been shooting uh
as a live action dp
a bunch of pictures for roger corman and
uh so that was the direction that uh my
career was going
um so my good friend john dykstra got
the
um the job to
do the main unit visual effects and they
invented this incredible motion control
system
which enabled uh you to shoot models
moving very fast uh you know in 2001 the
spaceships were moving so slowly that
you could just shoot them single frame
and and it was fine
but you know when you have a ship that's
moving really fast
um once again you know
the motion blur became really important
so that meant
that you had to shoot the model while
the camera
and the model were in motion so during
the exposure which might be as long as
four seconds or something
you know the model was actually in
motion and the camera was in motion at
the same time
and that took uh the invention
of motion control software
and it never been used at this scale for
so many shots um
before so so when um
george got back from shooting the live
action
in england he he walked into
uh industrial light magic and said well
where's the footage you know
and they really hadn't shot any footage
because they'd been
developing this hardware software system
and um so he got like he got really
frustrated
and he he
he called me up to to work on this
little
second unit
and he had this hair brain scheme
where he wanted some puppeteers in black
velvet suits
and he wanted to put the models on long
black rods and like
fly puppeteer them in front of a lens so
that they were
you know that the puppeteers were flying
the
so and so it was kind of like a live
action way of getting some of that
model photography well of course that
didn't work out at all it was a really
bad idea
but my unit then turned into this um
uh pyrotechnic unit and
uh there was this uh kid
jovis coastal who was who made real he
made these really great little miniature
bombs and
are you know he was um so we
so we started shooting these explosions
and we would shoot
i would look directly up at his
explosion so they would explode over the
lens
and therefore give it the zero g
impression that it was happening in
outer space because obviously if you
if you shoot an ex an explosion normally
you get a big mushroom cloud and it
doesn't
doesn't look like it's in outer space so
uh we started off letting these little
bombs off and it was
um quite successful and shooting them
with high speed cameras
and then we got bigger and bigger and we
moved on to much bigger stages until
eventually we
we had like a 40 foot blue screen and we
would drop the wire down
in the middle of that blue screen and we
would light the blue screen with like i
think there were
eight arc lamps you know which were the
most powerful lamps that you could get
in those days
and uh shooting them with a vista vision
camera
and we would we would shoot up through a
piece of glass which was
with two saw horses and a piece of
plywood and a hole
cut out to shoot through and then a
piece of glass
was over that to protect the lens and
then we
we let off these bigger and bigger bombs
until finally we had the uh
the explosions that we needed for uh
blowing up the
the death star and also for blowing up
alderaan
and um i also
shot a whole bunch of my friends that
industrialized magic were making all
these beautiful models and i got to blow
them up so
you know it was a fun little shoot
then the reception of the movie were you
anticipating the reception or
were you surprised i was very surprised
by the reception
of the movie you know i think we went to
see it at the academy theater and we
said hey this is this is really nice but
then like within a day or so
there were these long lines outside the
movie
and you know it's it's kind of a trick
that
theater owners do they like to keep
their audience wait waiting on the
street so it looks like a hit movie you
know so everybody drives by and see
sees a line of people but these were
like these were going around the block
you know
so um yeah it was um
unlike 2001 which had this
really kind of slow build um
star wars was like a instant hit you
know
and uh that summer but then who knew it
would grow into such a franchise and
around you know it just went from
strength to strength until it's
i guess the world's biggest franchise
right now huh
anything you observe with working with
george lucas in terms of how
he worked how he worked with actors his
work ethic
that you felt you wanted to emulate as
well
george was very
very good to work with he
really knew what he wanted and and where
he was going with it and he knew
what you he wanted you to do so
um i really enjoyed the fact that he was
so prepared
he also had um
uh he had a technique
which uh we now call a rip-o-matic
and that technique was to he got footage
from
uh old world war two movies like the
dambusters
and tora toratora and he basically cut
his end action sequence out of footage
from these world war ii movies
and then that became a template
for the effects because you know you
you'd go to the cut and you'd say okay i
need a
ship moving from left to right and
another one coming in this way
and um it's going to be 17 frames long
so it was a way of um you know they have
whole departments in movies now called
previews
for for doing this kind of work now but
back then this was a technique i had
never seen before
and it worked really really well
when you were hired as a cinematographer
on your first film
how prepared were you that first day i
think the first live-action film
i shot was for a was for a guy called
roy cannon who was stanley kubrick's
prop master
on 2001 and he had this little
dark noir um
murder mystery that he wanted to shoot
so we shot him
in a three-story walk-up in london
and um you know i
i have to say ignorance or arrogance i
don't know which it was you know it's
like i i
i knew how to load an aeroflex and uh
i had a couple of sun guns which are
handheld lights and i knew how to read
an exposure meter and i said i could do
this yeah
and so uh that was the first live action
tour make i shot
as um as a dp for somebody else
you know i obviously shot stuff for
myself
for uh growing up but you know that was
the first
so um i was probably very unprepared you
know
but i i seem to have a natural
uh bent for it you know and then
um the next live action feature that i
shot was um
with her friend that he was making kind
of um
a music movie and so it was
um it was a
very bizarre it was my it was like a
long music video
and i shot that
and i had a knack for
moving people into lighting that was
really good
so i i don't think i used the light on
that movie
but i was able to move
uh the action of the movie into really
great lighting situations
and shoot with natural light and
everybody everybody looked at the
footage and say hey this is really great
it
looks so natural and they're you know
alive you know
and that's because it was you know so um
it wasn't until much later that i
learned about uh lighting
and then i think as i learned about
lighting i think my
uh i think my work got worse
um in terms of it it had a very kind of
lit look to it
and then once i'd mastered those tools i
was able to use those same tools
to create very naturalistic lighting
um but with uh with artificial sources
so um there was a progression there but
luckily i know i never screwed up bad
enough not to get the next gig so
you know so the old saying you need to
know the rules before you can break them
kind of thing applies to the lighting
um yes i think so but
also i think
the lesson i learned that i tell people
that ask me what what they should do
is you know should i be should i
get a job as a loader and then be an
assistant cameraman
and then be an operator and then be a dp
and
my answer is that if you want to be a dp
that you go ahead and be a dp and
start shooting and um you know learn
learn from what you see from your
results
and you're probably going to find a
level as you as you
work your way up that you're you're good
enough for a particular project
you know but i think taking the um
taking the bit by the horns and saying
i'm
i'm going to do this job and
just try your hardest
every opportunity that you get to shoot
then i'm
that that that was my path
not the uh not the conventional path you
know
at what point in your career and which
project
where you headed off to set and you
realize wow this is i
you know i need to be really prepared i
can't mess up and then it might have
gotten in your head a little bit because
the stakes were higher
you know everybody kind of hopes to get
to a certain point and then there's a
new problem of wow no there's all this
pressure on you
right i think the most pressure i ever
felt was
[Music]
uh i did a project called the incredible
shrinking woman which was a movie with
lily tomlin
and um i decided to do all the visual
i was the effects the visual effects
director and the director of photography
and i decided to do all the um
all the effects is real projection and
front projection
which is a technique where you shoot the
actors
in front of the live live plates that
are being projected
so once you send that film to the lab
that's
you're done there's no optical process
there's no post process to that footage
and um this was
i was kind of out on a limb with that so
i was using
equipment that hadn't been used for a
long time which was best division
um rear projectors and front projection
equipment
and um i think there was a
there was a time when that process
wasn't going
really well you know and uh i i
felt that um
i felt scared that the process wasn't
going to come together you know
but it did so it paid off you know
but i think um
i don't think there's ever a day that i
go to work
if you know if i if i wake up for a
shoot day
and i'm not nervous or i've i haven't
had a shipless night the night before
you know then there's something wrong
i'm not doing my job you know so it's
always been
it's always been very uh stressful
because if you're not stressed
then i don't think you do any job and
then that's a great point because i feel
like now especially
in the kind of current state there's
like this i got this
mentality and it's almost considered a
negative
i feel like to some people to show or to
be nervous and i'm not talking about
fumbling and shaking and you know
tripping over yourself nervous but
just to to have some humanity to it and
and
you know it almost seems like now
there's a new
breed of of mindset any generation of
just sort of this i got this and
yeah i'm fine well i think was i in
a lot of people's work that i see these
days that are kind of up and coming
there's a bunch of stuff that they don't
know that they don't know
so um so they
they've got what they think is required
but
um if you're going to take it to a
higher art form
there's a lot more that you need to know
um
in order to get there but i think it's i
think it's a combination you've got to
have that
you got to have that attitude that you
know i can do this
it's going to be great but you've also
got to have the you know
you've got to know realistically what
your problems are going to be and
to do everything that you can to
overcome those so i think i think it's a
combination of the two things you know
who was the first legendary director
that you worked with and what was that
like for you was it stanley kubrick
it was stanley kubrick and um
you know having seen all his
early movies that i was exposed to by my
father he used to take me up to the
national film theater
in london and uh all
the the um
all the great directors at that time had
uh
films that were shown there but then the
guy that really stood out to me with
stanley kubrick so to be
working for him was really an amazing
experience and
i don't know how that happened but
[Music]
working for stanley is probably
the most informative experience i've had
as a filmmaker and to have it happen so
early in my career
[Music]
really i feel very blessed who was the
second
legendary director so you you had this
dream essentially fulfilled you probably
didn't
realize what an opportunity was maybe
you did at 19.
maybe you thought this was going to
happen all the time i don't know well
i think after 2001 you know i
it was a shock to come into the regular
film industry because i thought oh
all movies are like this you know which
was like a two and a half year
experience
um working in an environment
with my favorite director ever sitting
in dailies with him
answering to my footage that was being
shown on the screen you know
and um so
um i think that that experience of uh
having a really demanding director
looking at your work for
two and a half years is uh they can't
get much worse than that
or better you know
so the second most um
i'm not sure my my work with john
houston once
uh not for very long i i shot the first
few shots of um pritz's honor for him
so that that was amazing uh i worked
on the first star trek movie which
robert wise
directed and i shot the first
first five minutes of that movie um
so i think i think they really right up
there
absolutely when you went
back to work or to look for a new job
once
uh the kubrick you know film ended the
2001 space odyssey ended
then how was that an eye-opener for you
since you probably thought
this was going to become a pattern it
was going you were going to be working
on big sets
continuously after that point maybe yeah
no i
i left 2001
and went to the premiere in 1968 i think
it was
and uh i had hoped that i would go
on all of the uh other special effects
crews
uh went on to a picture called battle of
britain
which was being shot at pinewood studios
and i was not invited to that party
so um you know um
because really i was like doug
trumbull's guy and uh you know doug
left and went to uh to the states so
um so i found the british film industry
to be very clicky
um and it's very you know you have to
kind of like
nurture nurture your group there you
know but
i love coming to america because it it's
like
people actually want you to succeed here
you know so um
no offense britain but it's a little
different
maybe it's changed yes hopefully
so you came to wild and crazy california
yeah
uh had easy rider come out yet or was it
not yet not yet okay i came uh i came
over here to work on a picture called
zabriskie point
uh which was an antonioni movie and
antonioni was
another one of my favorite directors he
did a picture called blow up which was
like a huge
um
[Music]
revelation in terms of movie making to
me and i just love that movie
and it's about a a very fashionable
london store photographer that he
he's he's shooting some shots and
he takes the stuff back to his dark room
and starts
blowing up all the things and he
realizes he's witnessed the murder
that happens on film so he blows up the
pictures bigger and bigger and
it's fast fascinating movie uh but
yes i'm working for him on a picture
called briskey point and
basically at the end of the movie the
whole world blows up
and uh so we shot
a sequence which was uh supposedly los
angeles blowing up so
um we went out to the desert
uh to rosamund dry lake and we let off
thousands of pounds of napalm
with high-speed cameras and shot these
explosions at night
and we did this match shot and we put
them into this match shot and
it was never used in the movie but then
12 years later doug found this footage
in the room
in the cans that he'd been working on
and
ridley scott was looking for a snappy
opening to his
movie blade runner and so they used our
explosions
uh that we'd done uh in that opening
scene in blade runner where you're
flying over los angeles and all these
are uh
mushroom clouds of fire are going off so
it got used in the end you know did you
got did you get to go to the premiere
um of blade runner i didn't oh i was
gonna
see and it it's never been on my resume
but i guess it could be oh okay
i was wondering if you had met philip k
dick i think that was his last sort of
no no unfortunately not interesting
what do you think makes a great director
well for the longest time i was
trying to discern what that was you know
i think uh because
if you go on a set the kind of sets that
i like
um you you see everybody working
and you know the ads like shouting out
all the instructions and doing this and
that you know
and the whole movie is really taking
place in the director's head
so for me to go on a set and see what
the director's process is
is almost impossible because
if he's done his job right then
he's like he's cast the actors
and he's cast the crew
and when he gets to the set
except for like steering the ship a
little bit this way or a little bit that
way
shouldn't really be anything for him to
do you know he should be able to sit
back and let all these building blocks
that he's put together
to to come like before that camera that
day
um to let that happen now there are a
lot of directors that that's not their
style
you know and also when i'm
i i always seem to get myself involved
in projects that
i don't have enough time for so
time becomes uh and then i have to be
very proactive
and like okay the camera's coming here
yeah you know so
you can you can on those kind of movies
you can tell who the director is
but my uh my impression on going on
set with um
some of the great directors is that you
can't really see what their process is
it's
so um
yeah it's really hard to know what
people's process
is except by the quality of their
product you know
what do you think of the cliche that
some directors are
afraid of actors do you think that's
really true or do you think that
some people just operate better sort of
being removed and letting them do their
thing and it
gives the appearance of fear
well you know it's funny because kubrick
has a reputation of not really
um someone said i think that he
if he was a cgi animator he'd be able to
control
every aspect of his movie you know
because he you're doing it all pixel by
pixel but
um and i think some of his best movie
performances that he
got were from an actor called peter
sellers
and um i'm sure he was an actor that you
could just like wind up and
start shooting and there are you know
the performance is there
i think um i think a lot of
inexperienced directors are
afraid of the star power of the actors
that they're
that they're working with so they you
know they don't quite know how to deal
with that
and i think a lot of star power actors
working with those directors
are saying i'm not really getting enough
from you as a director
so i want to be directed you know so i
i think there's a lot of there's a lot
of layers
going on there you know but um
[Music]
if you are afraid of your actors um
that's not a helpful place to be because
those actors are your movie you know
and um i don't like to
give actors direction i like that you
know i've cast them
i've seen them in the thing and i'm i i
sit back and i
i want to see their performance now if
there's something that's not working for
me story wise
or we you know but um but i'll never sit
back in the chair and
and yell at the actor hey why don't you
do it this way you know so
you know for me direction is i'll i'll
get up out of my chair i'll go into the
set
take the act with one side and we'll
have a very uh
personal conversation about it so
um actors are your movie
you know what's the most important part
of the cinematographer's job
i think the most important part
first cinematographer is his
relationship with the
director and
basically as a cinematographer you are
there to facilitate the director's dream
so um
you know i think it's very important to
have a point of view that you bring to
it
in other words you've read the script
you you see the the movie in a certain
way
uh one of the first things i like to do
with a director that i'm about to work
with is to
get in the screening room and watch some
of the movies that we think are like
relevant to the one that we're doing or
or his favorite movies and i bring the
same thing to the uh
to the party so that we that we
watch other movies and uh we
come to a um
a symbiosis of
the way we're going to treat the
material because very often
on the set that everything's moving so
fast that you can't
you know you can't have that kind of
artistic collaboration number
because the actors are out there you got
to light it and you know you got someone
screaming at you
if you've been lighting that for seven
and a half minutes come on we gotta
we gotta go so uh in the heat of battle
um you can't necessarily have the the
the
kind of collaboration that you would
like but you
need to have set that up ahead of time
and um
that is your job is to is to bring a
visual
um a visual flair to the story
but at the same time um
you're there to facilitate the
director's vision
speaking of battle we hear sometimes
that a
cinematographer and a director will
clash and the cinematographer will say
i need this sort of this isn't going to
work
both to have a different agenda what
advice would you recommend to new
directors
and if they're in that spot and how do
they take it
away from the set i realize at times
it's going to be chaos you're not going
to be able to fight it
and you probably don't want to do it in
front of a crew but but if
faced with that dilemma which we've
definitely heard from a lot of people or
or you know just a clashing how do you
take that away from the set and just
try to make it through the entire
production well
um you know there was a reason that you
were chosen in the first place so there
must be
the there must be you know ines unless
you're a new director in the studio said
hey
we're going to put this all-time
cinematographer on your show and uh
he's going to make sure that you
finished it in 21 days you know
so there is that which and that's very
hard for a young director to
to work with but you know let's assume
that's not
happening and you know the director's
chosen you
and you you're working on this project
and
something does blow up that's exactly
what you do is you just
take them over and say hey let's take
this outside you know and
you have whatever that discussion is
going to be away from the set
because you know public
uh errands airing of grievances
has no place on a set for me sure
and last question in the same vein
someone left a comment which i thought
was interesting
and they said if you are either a dp or
a director
make sure you have some people in your
own camp
on set with you so that the production
doesn't run away
to somebody else's side and everybody
kind of turns
so do you have a core set of people you
always like to work with
not just for that that uh
possible problem but it was something i
had never thought of never having been
in that situation
but they said to always have some people
quote in your own camp because
things could quickly turn and then
somehow the production gets away from
one of the two well i'd say earlier in
my career
i lost jobs because i didn't have that
core crew
and you know the producer wanted to hire
somebody that
had his gaffering or you know everybody
in place
and they were a well oiled machine that
could come to work on his picture
you know um
working for years and years as a
commercial
director cameraman um i was
i had a different kind of most most
commercial directors they they're with a
company
and every time they go out they use
exactly the same people
i had a slightly different business
model in that i was a freelance director
so i would go out to like regional
advertising
and i'd go to a new city and i'd have to
put a whole
production together from scratch and in
that situation
i used maybe only be able to take like
one guy with me
and uh but i always i
i didn't always get that one guy but um
[Music]
i think it is really important you know
and
i actually used to take uh my key grip
which people thought was unusual people
who always say oh he's gonna take his
gaffer you know
or this because um and i used to
i renamed him from key grip to crew
chief which is that motor racing term
and it's really that the guy that runs
the whole physical
operation and he used to he used to work
for me in
in that area and that would let me deal
with the agency and the actors and
and the cinema so i think uh
i think crew members uh are very very
important that you have that shorthand
with that person um that you can get
things done very quickly you know
and time is the enemy so is it almost
like being in war
uh well i think it's much more pleasant
i would imagine um
but it is you know they're that they're
uh there are uh
there's a lot of money at stake and
um you know
um showing up is the first
rule so um being on time on a set is
like
is my number one rule and i probably got
that from being so arrogant about it
when i was a kid you know
uh but the kurt you know from the from
the moment you arrive
on a set the clock is ticking and i
i hear that i hear the dollar bills
dropping you know
and um so
um
i think it's um a strategy
that you in other words you have to have
a battle plan
to go into your day shoot and you have
to have
everything worked out to the nth degree
in other words when i do a schedule it's
you know it's it's it's every 10 minutes
so
10 minutes in i'm doing this 10 minute
unit
so because i i often get other people's
stats and people are like they're in the
makeup
trailer and they're like they're having
a cup of coffee and you know
and nothing's nothing's happening you
know
so for me the very first thing that you
do is you get the actors out on the set
and you block the first scene
they're not i don't care if they're in
makeup or what but the moment they
arrive on the set we block the first
scene
um so it's very important to have that
battle plan
to work with but then you've got to be
prepared to
completely throw that away if
either creativity or necessity
takes you off in another direction so
you've always you've always got to have
a plan b
and you've always got to be able to punt
if for
if things go in a different direction so
be totally prepared and then be prepared
to give it all up
you know is reacting to an image the
dp's only concern
while they are on set once the director
yells action
well once the um once the director yells
action
the die is cast you know so uh whatever
you bought
together but the dp's function is
um
i would say it was 50 uh
carrying out the vision the vision of
the director
and 50 management
of like the toys that he has and the
people that he has
and and how to get it done so um
you know there's a fast way to light a
set and there's a slow way to light a
set
and you know the the reality is that you
you're going to be in between you know
so um
i would say that's the only time when
the image is
um the only thing a dp has to worry
about is when the director yells
action because then there's nothing else
to do because if you've
done everything else that you that you
were there to
do and it's all to bring you to that
moment when he says
action so you're bringing everything to
a nexus at that
point and then then the movie is being
made
so you came to the states
from the uk 68 yeah came in 68.
do you think the film industry just
despite technical changes
is very similar here in the us i know
you came from what you thought was maybe
more of a
a closed network system and then you
come to this wild and crazy town and
there's music there's all sorts of you
know
different uh landmark things happening
at that time
but in some sense would you say that the
film industry has not changed
or is it different i don't think it's
changed at all you know
because um
the business is about telling stories
that's the bottom line and
the the art of storytelling
um i i guess it's made advances
because there are different tools
available there's a there's a wider
range
but there's a wider array of tools to
let you
tell more expansive stories you know in
other words
you know with the advent of uh cg
animation you can anything that you can
think of you can put up there on the
screen
so it's changed technically but
the bottom line is that telling a good
story
and what that good story is is virtually
unchanged
what about how one breaks into the
industry
i think it's much tougher for kids now
to break into the industry um
you know when i got hired on 2001 there
was really
virtually no one else they could they
you know i happened to be
this kid that had done an apprenticeship
in animation
camera work and i
i was not actually working for the
original company i had worked for
but i was off shooting and animating
from
for another guy but doug would come to
this original company
and one of the guys there had like
called me and said they're looking for
you know if you had a job in england at
a company
you you were kind of a lifer there you
know it's like you don't you you didn't
take a few months off to go and shoot
freelance for
uh two or three months on a on a live
action movie
you did if if that's what you did if you
were a live-action
person they were freelance but in the
animation business
people weren't freelance they were kind
of lifetime employees with the company
or they would move from animation
company to animation company to
long-term jobs
so um so it was very easy for me to
um
you know i don't know how effortlessly
it was whether it was because i had long
hair that i was
tired but you know it didn't seem that
hard and then
um as time goes by
um you know i think your resume builds
builds your next gig so
um but people
uh breaking in today i think it's much
much harder
a because the number of people that have
visual arts degrees
is like i mean that's you know half the
people in
university i think have that uh these
days you know
i mean it's like it's just a huge error
and there's there really aren't enough
jobs to go
around for those people but there again
netflix's and all the other streaming
companies there's
so much product being made that are that
that's a big equalizer so
there's a lot of work out there much
more than it was
when i started but um getting that work
is like you know the competition for
that work is much much greater now
when you came to los angeles what was
one of the first things you did to try
to land another job
well i came to los angeles with a job
that's right sorry
mr trumbull yeah so um
i was actually uh duggar told me that i
got this great
future for you in this little black room
in here and you know it kind of like
oh really and don't really want to be in
that black room
so um you know there were people who
would come into doug's studio that were
um
[Music]
uh that were working on very interesting
projects you know and i got to meet
those people as as they came in and it
wasn't
long before oh bruce bruce can shoot you
know let's i've got a little project
here you know
and and
you know i kept working on all my you
know i kept working
so that when i got that break i was
always ready for it
because i had done the homework you know
and kept doing that and then
things you know it always seemed like
you know i look back on my career and
people say oh god 2001
star wars tron you know all the
all these groundbreaking movies it seems
like i've had this
incredible run and i have but at the end
of each one
it just seemed like i was looking for
work and you know it
didn't seem that easy to do that but uh
but the resume helps you build that you
know
do cinematographers care about story
structure
i have to say that in the early part of
my career
[Music]
i did not and that was a big mistake
i think my career could have been
um a lot better if i had
um been more in touch with the structure
of the story
all my career i've been working
in the background on my writing career
and so from
from the very early 80s i've been
writing screenplays
and studying screenplays
and my work got better and better as
i was able to put together story
structure
with cinematography you know the other
place that i learned a lot about
cinematography was when i became an
editor and i was in the editing room
because
as a cinematographer you think when you
turn the camera on to when you turn it
off
that everything's got to be perfect in
that one shot and that's what you're
going for and you say oh well we missed
that little bit here and you know
and the reality is when that shot gets
to the editing room they're only going
to use that little piece of it so um
you can say that take has some really
good things in it you know so
we definitely print that one you know
even though it wasn't a perfect take
and the downside of that is that then
sometimes you see a really bad camera
move
being ending up in the movie
you know but at the same time it's it's
much better for the story and for the
filmmaker
so um
[Music]
i think having those parallel
disciplines um coming together has made
me
better in all those areas being a
cinematographer that's made me much
better writer than um than i would be or
director
you know so everything builds
on itself you know what were some of the
first screenplays you really dissected
once you got to la and you were you were
working
but you were doing this on the side
which was sort of this parallel talent
because one seems more action driven the
other one is more internal maybe maybe
not
yeah no i i think so um
[Music]
you know i i read some of my early
screenplay works and they're
you know they're completely without um
i mean i think the great thing about
screenwriting for me is
there are some massive hard and fast
rules of writing screenplays
but at the same time within that you
have this
infinite freedom and um
it's really the structure of it that
gives you that freedom so
yes there are rules but um there's this
uh massive you know uh
you don't drive between the lines when
you when you're writing you know
so the um
so the writing process i'm trying to
remember
what screenplays i really enjoy i i
think the first screenplay that i really
uh looked at and said this is a great
screenplay
is network
and also the verdict
is a is a fantastic screenplay to me
and um you know there are a lot more now
um um because i'm
because i really enjoy reading
screenplays you know
and i'm um just becoming a member of a
group where we we take a current
screenplay
and kind of break it down as writers and
filmmakers
so that's that's a very interesting
process for me
which i really enjoy so just as you had
done lighting on your own and people
complimented you on using this natural
light
but then you went and learned the formal
way and then it felt maybe
over produced and then you had freedom
to kind of
play within that that sounds like what
you've done with the right it's exactly
the same process with the writing yeah
you're right
when you're hired as a cinematographer
how many times will you read the
screenplay
for the film you're going to work on
well as i say in my early career not
enough times you know
now
the only time that you really get to
read a screenplay is the first time you
read it
and i think that goes for being a
director or um
or you know helping somebody else you
only get one
fresh read so you're only seeing the
movie continuously
once to be surprised by anything that
goes on so that
initial time that you read the script is
the most important
and it should be without a break um
you should never i think my acting
teacher nina fosh told me that
whenever you get a script all the way
through if you don't have enough time
that you can
sit down and read the whole thing you
shouldn't start it so
so i think that's initially that the
the thing is that after the third time
that you read it then now it's starting
to become really technical
because you're you're starting to see
the script in terms of the schedule
in terms of the locations where you're
going to do it
so at some point the the
breakdown becomes uh the bible that
you're working off more than the script
so there's a there's a there's a flow
into you know that first
fresh read uh which is what
which is the most important to
going into the schedule and the
breakdown
and seeing what it's going to take to
physically get the production done you
know
why did nina your acting teacher
recommend that you if you're going to
read the script you do it in one full
sitting that you don't take breaks that
you're not
sending an email texting
i think you know when you sit in a
cinema
and you you you watch the movie that's
how you're going to experience it
and very often if you stop in a script
and and you pick it up you'll say oh
there must have been a day break in
there and you say oh no the script
happens over 24 hours you know so
um you know i think it it messes with
your uh
sense of time that you're reading it and
it also takes away from the
you know the script is going to be
performed
in one hour and a half to our piece and
that's how you should experience it
and experience it the first time because
you're never going to get that first
read
ever again and that's why uh if i'm
if i'm writing something and i want to
get a reaction from somebody
i'll be very careful about who who i
show it to at what stage
so i might be i'm i might be getting
pretty close to something
and i've got to write a friend that
knows how to read
something in a rougher state and i might
show it to them but if i want to get the
i'll never be able to i won't be able to
use him again
because next time he reads it he won't
be reading it for the first time so
he'll have a different react
now it doesn't mean that the feedback
won't be useful
but it'll never be that first fresh read
which i think is so important
you know how many acting classes have
you taken
um
i don't know i did i did a a whole
session with nina fosh
um i've done some commercial acting
classes
um which were very interesting because
commercial storytelling is like you know
1.3 seconds is
the unit the time that you're working on
a little particular
thing and the production value that you
can put into that very short amount of
time
it's a very very interesting discipline
and i think from there so i think
three or four different acting classes i
took some improv classes
and but um i
then i kind of went into more i started
directing with more different people
which
was i'm headed more there than i am to
acting so
you know and where was this the
classes with nina with nina fausch they
were
um in a rehearsal studio um
above a bike shop on melrose avenue in
hollywood
and she had a nice nice little class you
know
do you have an internal checklist when
you're
reading a script before a film as a
director
as a cinematographer as a
cinematographer um
no i try to read the script
without thinking about anything and just
experience the
experience of script now as i say in the
technical process
later on then then the stuff
but basically by that time i'm usually
working off the location list
and the and the uh and the breakdown
whether it's day or night
and and you know becomes a much more
technical process but when i first read
the script
i try to be the audience and just sit
back and enjoy it you know
so then are there certain things that
you know within each scene
uh you have to sort of tick off in your
own mind
like a a checklist broken down to each
scene
once you've gotten through the actual
sitting down reading the script as like
the audience would experience it
now there's like a a list of
requirements for each scene
technically that you're checking on no
no i don't really work that way i'm
you know i have to say that um
you know people draw storyboards they do
little diagrams of how they want it to
you know they do little thumbnails
but the but until you get the actors
onto the set and they block the scene
because because it's
it's fine oh well in the storyboard
you're over here and you know
de niro is saying no i'm not standing
over here i'm gonna be right here you
know so
um so the blocking of the scene
is that to me is when the scene comes
alive and when my
work can really start because um
without seeing where the actors are
going to be you know lighting is very
active specific
you know you can light generally but if
you want to do something
very moody and special you really need
to see where they're going to be working
and until you get onto that set and see
where that is
and that's not until the director first
puts a scene together you know and
working with directors i would say
two-thirds of them don't know how
they're going to block it before they
get the actors
onto the set others have very specific
ideas but we're going to do it over here
and
you know but
[Music]
the blocking process is where the day's
work begins for me
you know and um checklists not not
really that's
a little too mechanical i you know there
are some
shoots that are so tight that i have to
order equipment that i need for that day
just specifically for that one shot and
you've got to do that but you know
it's you you if you're making a movie
you don't want to
say oh well we don't have any dollar
shots today so we're not going to rent a
dollar you know there are
some things that are going to be part of
your package and you're going to have
and they become the repertoire that you
use
to be creative and spontaneous
but then there are other times when you
know equipment is going to be
so expensive or the budget's so tight
you're going to have to say i'm going to
use this on this day and
and then you get very short specific
about
what kind of equipment you're going to
use in a certain place and what kind of
lighting equipment you're going to use
in a certain place
then how did storyboards weave their way
into
seeming like it's a normal part of
production is it just for some people is
the preference
well i think it helps
storyboards help um
non-visual directors visualize what
they're going to do
but really the birth of storyboards and
their greatest use to me
is in visual effects sequences because
then you're dealing with a discipline um
that's so specific to what's going to be
in that particular shot
and how the sequence is going to work
because there are so many
you know you you can't shoot visual
effects like documentary and
you know it has to be very specific
and um at that
time storyboards become the tool
to do that now
when you do a special effects sequence
in a in a
medium to a large budget movie now you
have a previous department
and storyboards have become now fully
uh fully animated uh sequences
that are done ahead of time and then
you're then you're kind of like
executing a an engineered movie
in the uh in terms of um
in in terms of uh what you're going to
need to bring
to a particular frame and shoot it a
particular way to get the movie made you
know
so um a lot of directors
um don't really like that process
because their their freedom of blocking
a scene kind of goes away
so i'm glad to say that in visual
effects now
there are a lot of tools that are being
developed from like virtual camera
systems
which are putting that creativity back
in the director's hands
about being able to be much more
spontaneous about
how things are going to be done uh i saw
something about rogue one
recently their animated battle sequence
is
actually shot by the director with a
handheld
virtual camera so he was able to
uh use that to um
be very creative and spontaneous about
the way he covered like a fully animated
battle sequence
do you remember where you were when you
learned of stanley kubrick's passing and
how did it make you look at
the life of a career well it was kind of
full circle with stanley because
i hadn't seen doug trumbull for many
years
and i happened to be working in his
studio in the berkshires uh
the day that i heard that stanley died
and i was working on a very kind of
high-tech virtual
set that combined puppetry with
cg images so that the puppets were shot
with a virtual camera
and the wherever the camera was was
driving a computer which showed you
where you were in this
three-dimensional reality so it was a
brand new technology
that doug had kind of pioneered
and i was up there seeing him and we
both got the news together
so um it was very sad so doug then
left and went to the funeral but i was
on this job so i was not able to do the
same thing
so sure did it make you look at
all great careers have some pushback
or you know like you can't be
an auteur without having extreme
criticism
in one direction the other that that's
part of the journey that's going to
happen
oh yes i think so that goes so much with
their territory of being an
artist you know is it
they're going to be the haters and
they're going to be the lovers you know
so
um but i i had wondered at the time
because
it was so close to the end of
uh i'd wise shut that i didn't know
whether he'd actually
finish the picture or not because it
hadn't been released yet
when he died and it wasn't going to be
for a little while so i i wondered
whether he had actually finished the
film but
uh i boo i believe he had and maybe
that was the sense of completion but he
did which would
would have been a lot better than uh
dying in the middle of a project you
know so
that was yeah i felt good i felt good i
felt
a life well lived you know
why did you write lost fair well i
co-wrote last fair
um i actually found
um a story on virtual pitchfest which is
a i'm a producer member of that
it's an online thing where people pitch
to
me the producer so they
they'll look through the people that
they can pitch to
and they'll kind of pick different
people if they like their resumes or
they like what they've done in the past
and they'll choose you specifically to
pitch their project to
and then you read the one page pitch and
if you like it you you you go ahead and
read the screenplay so
it's a it's a good project for writers
virtual pitch fest
very good um so i
found the project there and i'd been
looking
for something that i thought that i
could produce
um at a price
um and even though it had
kids in it and it was kind of a road
movie
and there were
there were things that i i mean
first of all i just i loved the the
premise i loved the characters
and i loved some of the dialogue um
but it wasn't really in a full
screenplay form
for instance the main bad guy in the
movie he was talked about
in the original script but he wasn't a
character in the movie
so there were certain formal things
and structural things that needed to be
done for the script
so that's why i got involved writing
with
rachel ray who originally pitched me on
the project
when you found the pitch on virtual
pitch fest what was it that stood out to
you
not the first time i've been asked that
question and it's
it's very hard to say i
you know it spoke to me and i think
that's the greatest reason to make a
movie is when when something really
speaks to you
and it was about this 11 year old girl
and um who had muscular dystrophy
so she was crippled
and she was not expected to live
more than a year or so during the time
that the movie was made
and she had been sold by her mother
and so it was a very dark story but it
also had
uh very kind of metaphysical elements
in the story so it was you know
um i've been meditating and
and studying western uh
esoteric philosophy for for many years
and
there's a thing about you know people
think oh i've got to reach higher
consciousness
but i don't if that's not enough you've
got to
spherically expand your consciousness so
you
you're reaching down into the depths as
much as you're reaching for the height
and and and the breadth of it and so
spherically
this movie was very dark and and very
light at the same time
and i think it was
i think it was elements of that that i
saw in the initial pitch
that really attracted me to it
so you contacted rachel or through the
website you can't
through the website i contacted
rachel and she she sent me the script
and then
somehow she
she got my contact information off the
web which is not hard to do
but um so she she started calling me and
she just like uh
she ravaged me with phone calls and all
right you know
so um i thought gosh
um so she was very tenacious
and um i said well
the chances of us getting this made as a
movie you know are
like you know 100 to one because that's
the way the movies are you know
so um you prepared to go on that journey
with me and she was
and so together we started whipping the
uh whipping the script into shape and
developing
characters and making it a makeable
movie and um um
the next problem that i had was that i
had an 11 year old
that was in every scene of a movie
that needed to carry the movie so
i decided that i wasn't going to make
the movie
unless i found that 11 year old girl
so i found alexis rosinski
and she is an amazing little
actress not so little anymore she time
goes by
and once i found her then i decided to
green light the movie and i was in a
position to greenlight the movie because
i was financing the movie
which is breaking the golden rule of
cinema which is never use your own money
but i love the project so much and i was
so into it that
i decided to do that and rachel
the writer that you co-wrote it with is
she based in l.a
no and i never met rachel until uh
sometime after the movie so we wrote
together remotely
and she's in a
in a wheelchair and she lives in
victoria columbia
and um i had a very nice visit with her
a few months ago i went up to visit her
and
got to meet her for the first time but
uh it's basically the story of her
the true story of her childhood so
it was pretty emotional you know to meet
her
ah so hence why she was so tenacious
about it
yes and um it was funny because she had
followed my career
she said well while her and her brother
were being
you know abused by her parents her
escape was into the movies
and so she knew of me through those
early credits and
uh it was weird and and
not only that when she made the pitch
she made a mistake she wasn't originally
going to pitch it to me she was going to
pitch it
because she didn't think it was my cup
of tea so she was going to
pitch it to somebody else so the pitch
came to me
without her really targeting me so
i guess it was meant to happen you know
did you outline the screenplay for lost
fair
well there was there was an outline of
what was going to happen in the
in the original pitch that was presented
to me
the physical act of outlining
no not not in the sense that i never got
the 4x5 cards and
pinned them up on the wall and reordered
them and so i never
i never approached the structure in that
way
it just it came it came across
much more organically than that i
in fact i worked giving notes
to rachel uh she did three drafts
so she said the draft that i keeping her
was kind of i
was was kind of the white washed bush
and i said give me your grittiest
version that you have
and then she did two more drafts after
that
and although they went
they were good but they went completely
in a different
direction so i was trying to focus
in a particular direction and stuff was
getting wilder and wild and that's when
i decided to come in and
start structuring so um so i did a draft
that was based on
three different drafts that she had done
and um
and uh then honed it down then i gave it
to some writer friends of mine
when i'm in doubt about structure uh
they're very
good because they're once again um
you can read i think the only people
that can't really see the structure of a
screenplay are the people that are
writing it you know
it's that you can be as area date as you
want about like
criticizing other people oh well this
this is no you know page five this
should have happened and you know
uh but you just somehow when you're
writing yourself
all that objectivity goes away so it's
very important to me to have
a cadre of people that i go to to
you know help me ground me in a project
you know
i'm lucky to have met those people
in my uh journey of writing you know
how was the dialogue when you first read
it
the dialogue was one of the things that
attracted me to it very much and there's
a lot of the original dialogue
in the um in the script now the
the stuff that i added but i tried to
keep it in the same
voices of those characters for instance
there's
she has an imaginary friend in the movie
that she speaks to who becomes a
character in the movie
and a lot of the dialogue between her
and her imaginary friend is completely
untouched from the original version
so um i i loved her dialogue
you know and i tried to keep it as
intact obviously it has to change when
you change the structure
and the overall thing and there are new
scenes but i tried to keep everything
um as as original as possible
because once again when
you when i read that pitch that's
that's the freshest and best it's ever
going to be you know
um you know after that you're not
objective on
because you've read it you've read it
once all your objectivity has gone away
in other words
and then then now you have to start
looking at the story logically
in terms of structure but that first
emotional
feeling that you get from the script
you'll never you'll never have that
beyond the first read so there were
three versions it sounds like that you
looked at the original
and you someone said it was too vanilla
and then a gritty version and then well
no um
i said um she said that she had
rewritten it
several times you know and i said well
is the is this the grittiest version
that i'm reading she said no
i put this version out because
um people had told me people that she'd
shown the project to before had said
no this is this is too dark i'm not i'm
not going to be able to make this you
know
um but here i was asking her for her
darkest version of it you know
and it's the darkness uh combined with
the
the light metaphysical that i found so
interesting about the
uh about the project because it's very
dark and
and very hopeful at the same time
so do you think if you hadn't been
studying
you said western uh so not buddhism
i'm sorry esoteric philosophy
i i say that because then it's not
religious okay i'm sure
non-denominational yeah right um
if you hadn't been studying these
different uh
types of philosophy would you be
attracted to something that would be
maybe considered very dark by some
viewers
i probably would have um
veered away from it i would think
and i think it's only but you know it
that whole training um
in that particular discipline
is life-changing anyway so who knows who
i would have been
as a person without having done that you
know but
so um i'm i'm i'm really a believer in
the fact that you are exactly where you
need to be
and everything that's happening in your
life is
for the perfect reason and you know
nothing happens by accident so that's
that's my philosophy so i don't think
um i think i would have been attracted
to the story
but who knows because i was who i was
when i read it
where does the movie stand now well i
think we're just
coming up to 10 000 streaming minutes on
amazon so um i think that's good
um but i i don't really know the
our distributors are they're great
they've got us into a lot of different
places but they don't
they don't give me a lot of information
about
on a daily basis how it's doing but they
will they'll send me amazon
things on a monthly basis so i can see
so i can see how it's performing but i
don't have any other information about
any of the other platforms that it's
running on because it's on a bit
on about six different platforms so
so i would say the movie is doing really
well you know and um
indie rights who is our producer they're
very happy with the movie
it's the best grossing movie on
on amazon so
they i think that i think the movie is
doing well
what's been the feedback from like the
verified rentals or
i don't know um the just
really that amazon number the 10 million
streaming minute i don't know what that
means in terms of how many people watch
the movie
i know you get paid by the minute that
it's streamed
so um and the
the pay scale changes if you do if you
do well
and your numbers are up you get paid
more on the next
or the next month or so you know or
three months
so um financially i don't know how the
movie is doing yet
but um it
it looks like it's doing well how did
you teach yourself the craft of
screenwriting
well like everything else in my life i
just started doing it you know
and i i look back on some of my earlier
efforts and
it's abysmal you know it's it's tough
um i read a lot of books
uh read all the required true bee
or uh um i think that the book that i
enjoyed
best was a dramatic screenwriting by
lego segre and it's actually a book
about playwriting
but i got a lot of out of that book in
terms of
um he has a
uh i think that he calls static conflict
and a lot of stuff that i wrote had
static conflict in it and you have to
have you have to have a rising conflict
you know so you the conflict is going to
come out of your characters
but if that's uh if that doesn't move
that conflict doesn't grow and
complicate uh then it's just
you know static conflict is you say oh
well my script's got conflict tonight
yeah well it does
but the conflict isn't moving so that
was a very important
lesson that i learned from that that
particular book on screenwriting
playwriting were there parts then that
you went back in
and said yes there might be an argument
seen here but it's not moving the
story forward how can i you mean on a
specific script that i'd
for lost fair oh for lush fair um
so i think i i think i wrote um
fair more instinctually than i think you
kind of
internalize the rules that you learn and
um you know i will look at a script and
and i get to page 30 and i say well have
i got to the first turning point
or you know i'll read 10 pages and say
do i know what
do i know really what's going on here
have i been set in motion
and but i think when i'm writing myself
i
try not to use those rules i will come
back and look at it after
after i've done the writing work but
um i try to let the rules kind of like
be part of the language that's working
in the background
rather than try to follow them as i'm
writing and i try to write from the
heart
as as as the process of
actually putting the words down on paper
you know
the other thing i find about writing is
that i find the muse does not visit me
until i'm in the act of typing
and you know i can go on you know it's
fine i can go on a hike
and i can think about the characters and
you know but
nothing creative really happens until
i'm actually physically
in the act of writing that's just i
don't know if that's true for anybody
else but it's true for me
so did you set times for yourselves i
mean if if she's sending you
one draft or different notes or
different things or is there a
specific time you're working on um
you mean time of day yeah like a time of
day place did you really have to
hunker down and say i need to be more
disciplined because now
this isn't just someone's script it's
also their life and their life story
um i
don't know i think writing is like
painting for me i get completely lost in
it
so for me there's not a particular time
of day i don't have to
you know some people like to write late
at night because the internal edit
gets smoothed out i don't know whether
it's good they've had a couple of drinks
or not but
there are some people like to write them
but for me
there's no there's no time of day
there's no place
it's completely uh you know the the
energy and the love of the project is
what like
drives me to it so there's it's never a
chore to come and sit down i thought oh
where was i you know it's like um
for me it's it's just a
an innate energy that happens you know
was there any pushback with you
also being the director so co-writer
producer
and now directing lost fair no i think
you know it was a given and in other
words
this whole project is coming together
for me to make this movie i'd had
uh in the previous two years i'd had
three projects
that came to within two weeks of
commencement of principal photography
uh only to have the financing pulled or
to you know and
when you're that close you've already
made the movie you've you've
um you know you've broken down the
script you've cast it you've
you know you've done all this stuff and
so it's like
um like a miscarriage you know i mean
it's
it's so awful and uh i decided i wasn't
going to let this happen
this next time i was going to make my
own movie
and lost fair was the perfect vehicle
for it
were there times where you would wake up
in the middle of the night and say am i
really doing
this or or it was just this is i know
this is the right time for me
especially this new mindset i'm adopting
or
whatever yes i think you we wake up in a
cold sweat
you know am i really going to do this
you know
and even on there was a there was a time
where it actually it was the first day
of shooting
and um
[Music]
um we were shooting some car sequences
and um alexis was in the front seat of
the cab
and her mom came and said where do we
disable the uh
the uh um she's
she's not going to get in the cabin as
we disable the uh
the airbags you know and this is an
older car and you can't disable the
airbags so
um you know it would have taken a
mechanic to come you know
and if i said okay i'm not making a
movie
so even even on the first day of
principal photography there was a there
was a
chance to pull back you know and not do
it but
um that that didn't happen so uh
because um
when i finished the script and i told
elliot rosenblatt my co-producer
how much i wanted to spend on the movie
or how much i could spend on the movie
he said well
all right uh i can make that stretch to
11 days
so um i thought 11 days i've
you know i've made some 18 day movies
and i thought that was about as fast as
you could make a movie so 11 days was
you know when you when you were on that
schedule
nothing can go wrong so it really i mean
the planning of it and how it
how it works needs to be down to the
15 minute segment you know and um
you know so it's probably um
an ogre trying to get that done so if i
if i had pushback it was probably
because i was like so moving ahead and
blindly moving ahead
not blindly but just focused on
on where we were going you know did you
have to have a tutor on set
yes yes so 13 days tutor on set
11 days 11 days i'm sorry okay and a
tutor on the set
and we're making a road movie so that
means that uh
you know we have car car photography
inside the cars
which is very time consuming you know
normally you get a car and you
put it on a process trailer and then you
light it and then you've got certain
angles and then you tow the car
you know i just had to i got these two
uh
cannon um xc10s and suction cup mounts
and i just put them on the windows
and they just said okay go driving and
do the scene so i never really i never
really got to see those car scenes
except when they came back and usually i
didn't have time to like rewind the
footage and
i had to rely on the actors and say did
you get it you know yeah we got it you
know
but i would have them do the scene maybe
three times so at least i had some
choices with it you know
so um yeah pretty
pretty grueling little schedule you know
is this your first feature directing
credits it's the first
movie that i've been so involved in i
shot a picture for roger corman
in the uh in the 80s called the vendetta
which is a women in prison movie um
kind of a cult classic it's got a pretty
good rating on imdb
but uh um but this was the first
um as an auteur this is the first
project that i'd done yeah do you plan
another
i do i have a project called garden
country
and it's about
a marine pilot and she tries to go
through the justice system and it fails
her
and she takes matters into her own hands
time not a tough story yeah and a timely
one at that time
you seem to be drawn to female
protagonists i do
what's what's that i don't know yeah
um before it was fashionable now now now
it's a
it's almost a requirement if you're
going to make an action movie you've got
to have a female
hero but when i was developing those
other projects it was not
um except for norma ray
i guess well yeah they've been they've
been acceptance to them
but i i i pitched garden country i think
i've been i've had that project in the
back of my mind for a long time i
pitched that to someone and said oh
female protagonist no no
we're not we're not interested in him
did you you co-write it i'm sorry or you
garden country um i co-wrote with
um one of my most trusted
uh writing partners i love to write with
partners because
um you you know you're writing dialogue
so that's two people back and forth so
it makes
makes sense to me to have two people in
the room you know but
it but it's a it's a tricky relationship
so you can only do it with
certain people but i wrote this with
steve finley who i've probably written
maybe four or four different screenplays
with over the years
and so it's my original screen story and
and we wrote it together now originally
i wanted
steve not not just because i enjoy
working with him but
i needed to get this off the press
really
quickly because um
about four years ago when i started
writing it
um there were many documentaries about
rape in the military
and um i thought this is a topical
subject that's got to happen really
quickly but
unfortunately that uh that has
legs um the whole situation and it's
worse now than
uh than it was when i started writing
the story you know
at what point in your career did you say
i want to go from being the
cinematographer to the director
or was that always a plan it was always
the plan
um i think um
as i described when i was talking about
my special effects career and then my
i i spent the early part of my career
saying
okay i've done that i now i want to move
on to this
and i've done that now we're going to
move on to this but
as i get later in my career i like to
bring all that stuff together so
you know stuff that i've done is stuff
that i want to do again so
this new project that i have involves
visual effects
it's going to be a very strong i'm sure
i'll use a dp
but has a very strong visual sense to it
and uh you know as a director then
the characters are the most important
thing to me so
but yeah it it it's always been the plan
and what about the darkness level of the
screenplay
knowing that it's a very um you know
traumatic topic
um how how much do you plan to go dark
and how much do you plan to
have other parts to it well i think the
i the screenplay has been in the draw
for a little while
and i showed it to a friend recently
and he was very excited about it so i
reread it and i'm going hey this was
really good who wrote this stuff you
know this is good
i and so um
i found the screenplay on rereading it
the darkness is there uh but the
excitement is there and the um
and i wouldn't say comedy but the the
the lightness of the human condition is
there so um
it's i wouldn't call it a dark and samba
script although it deals with a very
dark subject you know
what's been the easiest year for you as
a filmmaker
last year i think
um i think the tools that
are available uh for filmmakers now
it used to be that to make a movie
you needed this huge infrastructure
technically
um you you needed these cameras and then
you needed the stuff to go to the lab
then you need to bring it back
and and make a print and then edit it on
a moviola and
cut the negative and mix it and
and all those tools from the cameras
to the editing programs to the
vfx software
of all become totally available to
everybody
which to me has democratized the whole
filmmaking process
and um i think it's absolutely fabulous
that anyone
with a vision and and and you know
if i don't know how to do something i
just go i watch a
youtube video on how to do it and i
teach myself how to do it but i guess
i've done that my whole career but
now it's so available that you know
um yesterday i'm looking at some
budgeting um
software so i'm watching some youtube
videos
and it's it's available
it's out there so i think it's easier
to be a filmmaker now than it ever was
what's been the most difficult year for
you as a filmmaker
i don't know all movies are difficult
you know
um and usually if a movie is easy
and you're really having a good time
while you're making it
my experience is it doesn't turn out
very well you know
um now some some projects have been like
real
nightmares uh because of the
you know some some directors
they like to create really negative
energy on the set
and they work off the kind of energy
of the people that are working for them
that they're consummate professionals so
they dig their heels in and say i don't
care what he says i'm going to do a
great job
but i don't like creating that kind of
energy on a set to me
[Music]
you know projects flow
they flow out of love of and everybody
working in the medium that they're
loving on a story that they love
and um so i've worked with some
difficult people
but um i try not to be one although
i have to say on my last movie i
i told my producer you know because
basically i made it with a bunch of
young kids
because i had 11 days
they had to have experience but they
couldn't be
you know my cinematographer basically
i'm doing street theater and i'm
covering it with two cameras either
over shoulder both sides or wide and
tight from one side and then from the
other side
so um so i was i'm and
you know i'm moving along i'm pretty
tough so i said to my producer oh yeah
that one guy in the art department he
didn't like me you know
and elliot said nobody liked you what
are you talking about you then so
i guess i guess i'm tough
well it's a weird thing when someone
sort of at the helm of the ship
yeah because it's easy to
find fault and everybody has different
angles for wanting to
take somebody down a couple notches or
whatever so everybody's kind of angling
right and so you can be a politician as
much as you want with certain things but
there's always going to be
anglers right in the water you know i
agree
and and i think um
i think when you're making a movie
um and you're focused on
on a really tight schedule um
it's very you know if
if anything uh it is negative about the
process
it's the clock that's ticking and it's
getting the stuff done in
in the right amount of time and as as
the director
that's your that's your greatest
ally and your biggest enemy is the clock
and you you can't rely on you know i can
say well
the assistant director he didn't move it
along fast enough well this guy didn't
do this so
you know that the the buck stops with
you
and you're financing it as well so
boom you know
i hope it's never that tough again but
it was
a very lovely process as well so
why do you think people fail in
hollywood i think people
fail because they fail to realize
uh how tenacious you have to be
and the all the rejection that you get
and this is the hardest for me to say is
like
when you get that rejection you know
you're one step
closer to the one person that's going to
say yes you know
and you have to go through so it's a
it's 110 one you know
you have to have 100 meetings and 10
people
say yes and one person actually does it
so
it's um
i think other reasons that people fail
are because they
let i've seen a lot of directors that
say i'm the director you know
and it's like they're not really coming
from a place of
knowledge and love of the material you
know
they're they're really they're playing
the director you know
and um usually when people
don't really know what they're doing
they also get very insecure
and um and therefore
very mean to people because things
aren't going the way they should and
they're looking to play the blame game
you know um i think another reason that
uh i think a reason that i probably
haven't gone further is my
inability to network as well as i should
uh i've always always found that very
difficult
it's very very hard for me to go into a
room and
work the room you know they'd kind of
stand in the corner and
sit my cappuccino you know
but i think if i had it to do over again
i would
i would work on that i also had a big
problem with public speaking
which i went to toastmasters to
kind of overcome and now i do a lot of
uh talks at comic-cons
and teaching different places in the
industry
and that working on that
has really allowed me to move forward
have you ever thought of what your life
would have been like
if you hadn't had that opportunity to
come to california
and you would you might have been sort
of metaphorically banging your head to
get into this closed
click well if i'd stayed in england and
and
work the system i guess you know it
it almost seemed to me like it's it's
whoever
bought the you know you'd go to the bar
after after work
and had to buy a round of drinks for
everybody and
uh you know it was it's very very
transactional there can
it um
[Music]
no i i you know even even before i had
the opportunity i
uh i was always going to be in los
angeles
my my mom had she'd travel around the
world her aunts had sent her around the
world before she got married
and um and
you know i had this national geographic
uh that
showed me the los angeles basin the
disney studios oh there's disneyland
20th century fox you know i was always
going to be here i don't know
so i didn't i don't think the option of
staying in england ever would have
happened but i
i probably would have navigated that
system okay you know
because my passion was to be in the
business
where does your tenacity come from
because you sit before us sort of like a
with a monk like uh you know resolve and
i
i don't see like a you know you don't
like networking and i see somebody who
seems more even keel but where does that
tenacity come from
with your career i don't know i think it
comes tenacity is not in the moment for
me
it's over a much longer period of time
but you know my career it looks like a
dream from great project a great project
but
in between it always seemed like you
know
never going to work again you know how
am i going to deal with this where's the
next job going to come from
you know the good news is that the
resume builds
builds on itself so that's that's a good
thing but
um it's i think it's just a
slow forward movement you know this is
where i'm going and you never
lose sight of that but it's not like
it's not like holding on
tight to the moment or to any particular
one thing i mean there are
there are times to do that but i think
it's a
it's just a long slow process you know
so um i get but i guess it looks like
tenacity you know do you see
whether from your own family or whatever
just
younger people wanting things faster and
not wanting to
you know whether it's children in the
business or whatever just
a certain route whereas before you had
to more take your time with it now
everybody wants to jump ahead and do
something
times have changed yes i i do i think
i think the kids today the kids today
i think they have it much harder because
um even even though there's a lot of
product being made now um the
competition
to get that work is much stiffer than it
was when i started out
um but i do also
see the lack of you know when it doesn't
come
quickly they kind of like move on to
something else you know and i think it's
only
by maintaining the focus you know and
you're gonna get
you're gonna get knocked down a whole
bunch of times
um but you just gotta you just gotta
keep going you know
yeah and you saw your your parents were
in the industry is that right or at
least yeah
yeah yeah my um i
my dad worked as staff at the bbc
so i didn't see the the kind of
competitive aspect of what i needed to
go through to have a successful career i
didn't see him tackling those same
problems
but i think he definitely gave me the
the background and the beginning of that
knowledge you know
because i would go to dailies with him
and you know
her bbc shows were done half in the
studio
and half as filmed elements and they
would like
combine them and it was weird because
uh the in studio stuff was at 60 frames
a second and then the empty suddenly cut
to this 24 frame a second
so it didn't look like the same piece of
meter at all but
anyway they did that but i would watch
him i would go filming with him
i was never in the studio with him but
um but he would take me on location
and uh you know he would look at a
film and he said every every picture on
there every picture should be
a perfect picture you know so
uh even even though it was a movie you
know so the composition is going to be
right so he gave me this whole
kind of basis and
i think his ability to work with actors
which he was really known for
you know and he was known for really
good casting so all those
all those things were achievable to me
it doesn't mean i was good at them when
i
when i started but it was not was not an
impossibility i could
i could see light at the end of the
tunnel you know but at the same time
when you came to california you knew
that that little dark
room that you had been offered
quote unquote job is not for you yes
no definitely not for me and and and
you know going on to the next thing was
not necessarily
um how you build in other words i never
i never built a really great
dp career i mean i i had a dp career
and you know i've worked on some really
really great projects but um
i think um i think you
you're taught that you have to focus in
a particular area and i do see
if you wanna if your ambition is to be a
great dp
then you really have to focus on that
but my
mind was not to do that so i really took
a dp career into
a commercial uh directing career
and that way you know i i must have shot
like 300
television commercials and each one
is like a little production so you're
going through that
even though it's for a much shorter
period of time you're going through the
casting process the location process
the the equipment process and the post
process
you're going through that many many many
times you know so that was
a really good training for me and then
you know the writing happened on a much
slower
level but studying acting and directing
while that was going on has brought me
to where i am now you know
what are some things in the last five
years you've learned that you wish you
knew
previously i have to say it's probably
the ability to network
and also to cold
call companies or
and not really mind the rejection as
much as i used to
so um i think it's
um you know
i i look at my age and say but if you if
you can't make that telephone call now
you're never ever going to be able to
make it so
so i think it's a more relaxed attitude
about what's going to happen and
a lot of a lot of the last five years
have been uh making this movie
uh last third i would say maybe three
years of it from the beginning to now
and that's a that's a lifestream come
true
so um i'm feeling really good about
stuff now
and why would you be cold-calling uh
companies uh
to to sell the next project
so you've got to get past the the
gatekeepers you know that are
preventing you from getting to the other
person that can read your script and say
yes to it
because my next project is not something
i can sell finance so i have to
i have to sell it i'll get it out there
you know
do you think people are less apt to say
no
these days you just don't hear from them
do you think before people gave you a
clear no
or yes maybe now nobody wants to hurt
anybody's feelings
um everybody's sensitive so now i think
it's a bit like when i was in the
commercial business people
made a lot of commercials in japan and
they used to say well when you're
talking to
japanese companies you know it's like
yes means maybe
and maybe means no so
uh i think
um
i i don't think people say no leaves
some do
very quickly very professionally you
know
they'll read it right away and most most
just like disappear into the ozone
and you never hear from them so which is
why it's important
you know earlier in my career i would
like send my script out oh please read
my script and then you'd
wait six weeks and not hear from them
and you know
so now it's just like three companies
every day you know you just
you know there's a lot of a lot of fish
in the sea you gotta
just keep going and keep it out there
and i'm a lot better than that
at doing that than i used to be so
do you really think networking helps
with success
yes i think people like to make movies
with their friends
and they want to be they want to be
friends and those are the
projects that get made you know
other than the whole kind of
impenetrable um
situations that a lot of movies are
deals they're not
they're not really like you know we
think of them as like
creative projects but it's the film
industry
so um you know it's
a lot of the big movies that get made
their deals they're not
they're not creative projects like they
used to be in the old studio system
and so i think that's why you see a lot
of projects that are not
cast well because um
we got the script we got this actor he's
interested
and you know you know
movies are put together and engineered
more than
being um works of art
and and love that get made by people
that except for some art house cinema
that i've seen recently
yes it's been quite good yeah no
independent cinema is
still alive and well and actually a lot
more alive and well
um i have to say lost fair is
goes into that category you know and
um there wouldn't have been an outlet
for those
uh movies this movie would never have
got distribution
five years ago you know would have been
very very
difficult but now with streaming
services
once again it's democratized the whole
process you can make a little movie and
if you make it well people want to watch
it you know so
that's great did it have theatrical
distribution
it had a it had a weak um
theatrical unfortunately it was supposed
to run
three times a day instead of once a day
and therefore i wasn't
it wasn't eligible to uh
for academy consideration and the reason
that i wanted to do that was because
that gives you an opportunity to mail
out
dvds and blu-rays to a lot of people in
the industry so
whereas the movie has done well um
commercially or
is doing well commercially not that many
people
inside the business have seen it so
that would have been nicer so we live
and learn you know
tell us about the biggest success you've
had in your career
uh it's always my next job it's the
biggest success that i'm going to make
it so
[Music]
i think i've been so lucky throughout my
career would be very hard to
pinpoint one high point
but
when i look back on you know what i have
achieved i
i didn't realize what i'd achieved until
i started doing comic-cons and
people would come up to me and said oh
gosh yes
star wars that's that that's why i got
in the business when i saw that movie
or i've had people come up and say yeah
i saw your movie tron and
uh i decided to be a software programmer
and
this and that until you see what
so i would say the big success is the
body of work
and the influence that it's had on on
people
so that sounds like it's something that
you're not able to see right away it's
going to take time and then
interactions exactly
did it make you look at the projects you
worked on because you knew
how much struggle or whatever was behind
it but then to have someone approach you
after you were on a panel or something
right and and say that
well it certainly made it all worthwhile
you know so
right did you always know you were going
to work at higher levels
in the industry i always aspired to work
at higher levels
i didn't know i was going to get what i
was aiming for but
i've achieved many many of the things
that i wanted to
and there will always be people that are
it's like
[Music]
it's like in racing there's always
somebody faster than you and there's
always somebody slower than you so it's
like
you've you've you've achieved greatly
but
um you'll never get there you know
i think competition matters less um
[Music]
and maybe after like 35 is there so much
pressure on people like
do this do this do this by age whatever
and it seems like the
used to be 40 and now it's 30 and now
it's 25 and
you think as as time goes on people
let competition go because even if they
have achieved it
they go yeah but was was it enjoyable
well for me it's been enjoyable on every
step of the uh on every step of the road
you know
i think i think there is that pressure
and i've put pressure on myself to do
that
i don't really feel like coming from uh
coming from outside because people
people always say
gosh look what you've done you know but
for me it's never enough you know
so that's always what pushes me on to
the next thing so i think
i think competitiveness i think i
competed with myself you know
i think that's that's how it works for
me you know
i mean and of course there are people
like gosh i wish i'd done that i wish
i'd made that movie i wish i'd you know
i wish i was on my 10th or
uh feature grossing or a hundred million
dollars in it but
um i'm i'm where i am i'm very content
with that now
and so i think as time goes by you're a
little
you're a little easier on yourself
right yeah sometimes i see
younger people and they just seem so i
mean they have to have something
no matter what the cost and i'm just
wondering is
society sped up they watch their parents
lose things during the recession
or struggle during the recession and
then it's become even more like life or
death
sometimes i see that in people well
desperation is uh
not a good feature it doesn't do that
desperate feeling doesn't do well when
you're interviewing for a job
it doesn't do well for yourself while
you're trying to achieve something so um
yes i think a lot of people do feel that
but i don't think it's constructive to
their careers at all you know
right i think some people though are
hardwired to be more competitive than
others
i guess that's the american way huh
maybe that's true yeah
you